Mr brownfields welcome
I am
the actual you will make a very good
assistant no he's evil we will protect
you you have the word of the most
trusted institution on Earth the
Catholic Church
[Music]
Renfield you're so purpose in life is to
serve me now let's eat
I just want to know more life again
[Music]
no no no no no no no
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
real
thank you
it's a homie The Dark One
so you bring and people to eat well I do
other stuff like what washes Cape the
Cape is dry clean only strictly yeah I
will wear this this fly yeah
because I don't think he's just a bad
guy but you're never really going to be
free until you face him I will no longer
tolerate abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering I will
Unleashed everyone you care about will
suffer because if you trade me we have
to stop him Before Sunset
I
deserve happiness and I take full charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse
everything I saw you do today is going
to be my way worse my least favorite
part of the job
[Music]
um